I'm sorry. I thought, okay, I need to I need you guys to understand
how I went into this content. I thought that we reached the worst
part of him crying before this. I do think he is actually possibly
crying now.
And you have anything else? I just I don't get >> uh and
I don't I don't know what you have to harp on it. >> I
I don't think I've harped on it, though. If anything, I've defended
you multiple times in this conversation. >> I agree. And
Dan's just not really speaking up, but
>> All right. All right. All right. All right. Dude, this
Zip I've heard this Zip Zip stuff is very, very, very funny.
Okay.
Heard it's very funny. Did I hear that? Did I hear right the
other night when Zip Zip threatened to unzip? Okay, dude.
Uh, okay. We're We're on to the Zip Zip stuff. This is Zip Zip
Loot and Danva.
Apparently, they went pretty hard on this guy. Give me Give me
a second.
So, Zip Zip joins. Now, I can't remember if before this Do I
need to go backwards? So, I I'll just lay it out. I believe before
this they were talking about like who would betray Destiny, who
might betray Destiny, who might be the next JTO.
Absurd. Absurd framing, but I believe that's what was being discussed
here. Let me let me check it out. I think you have a I think
you currently have a 20% chance to flip. I would say food shops
in my mind
>> 90 maybe 99. I'll put it at 90. >> I I think food
shops in my mind is a ticking time bomb >> that and they
>> Hey, why were you gone for so long? I
>> Why were you Why are you gone for so long? I forget.
Why'd you have to point out that like you were totally hard done
by because of how audit reached out and Destiny wouldn't even
reach out to you? Why'd you do a whole thing on stream about
it? What was what was going on there, man? They are going to
flip. She I think I think food shops has shown a propensity to
lie for Destiny. Mr. Moot, he gets all in his feelings and wants
to be treated like a human being. He wants like respect and and
compassion from other people. He gets all in his feelings. He's
like, "Oh, you should treat me like I'm your friend." Uh, that
is a clear sign. That's something I do. That's extremely JCOD
to demand respect. That's extremely J. Dude, I think this guy
this guy's the biggest most likely to flip. The biggest one.
Okay, he's most likely to flip.
This guy demands respect as a human being. Food Chops demands
nothing like that. Food Chops is willing to let Destiny do anything.
>> She is absolutely going to become a hate watcher in
my opinion. >> A Destiny hate watcher. >> Oh, big
time. >> Why would you think that? >> General vibe
of >> You know what? >> It came to me through divine
revelation.
Oh, hey. Hey, zip zip. Zip zip. Good luck, buddy. This is a This
definitely um you've definitely
not earned this one iota. Okay. For them to just say they have
a vibe that you're going to flip. You and your friend are going
to flip. You haven't earned this at all.
>> There's no actual reason. >> I got >> The
best part is if I'm I'm helping Zip Zip right now. He doesn't
even know it, but I'm actually helping him because if they go
and show if he goes and shows clips of me laughing at him, that
like raises his estimation in Destiny's community, okay? Like
that's like I am I am consistently helping this guy by laughing
at him. If if I show disdain for Zip Zip, he like suddenly becomes
cool in DGG's eyes. Is very awesome. And now I'm just like yo-yoing
back and forth between who I support. Okay.
didn't expect food shops to totally own Dan and Mutton the other
day. Okay, that she came out, she got a ceasefire after she threatened
Dan after she basically said she was okay with Dan's kids and
wife being harassed. Listen, I didn't expect that. That was against
all odds that Dan bent the knee after that. Okay. Wasn't expecting
it. Came out of
Boot traps on the ride. >> That makes sense, man. >> You
don't get to say no actual reason when we've predicted a thousand
people doing this in the past. So yeah, >> I got a six
sense
>> before doesn't mean that you
you can just say it's just vibes and there's no actual like evidence
or basis to actually believe it.
>> I mean I got I got evidence and basis if you want I
can find it. I have to go through my DMs.
>> Uhoh. Mutton thinks he's got evidence and basis. Let's
go. >> All right. Give me two minutes. I don't even know
if >> I don't like how every morning this is becoming like
drama. >> That's a oneway I didn't ask for you to come
in here. That's a oneway street. I was talking about you channel.
So if I'm going to get talked, I'm going to come in and defend
myself.
>> I don't think we really did much
>> You said that I'm on a different team, that I'm not
loyal to DG. >> Dual loyalty, >> I have potential
to flip like Jto. >> Well, yeah, I think so. You're JTO.
No, you're JTO. No, you No, you're JTO.
It's like actually, Dude,
this man is an enemy of the party. This man is an enemy of the
party. I can sense it. I can feel the vibe, dude. It's like explicitly
It's explicitly reporting your neighbors as reactionary. Okay,
I believe I believe Zip Zip is a secret reactionary. Okay. Please,
please,
please come take care of him. Send him to the goolog.
>> Yeah. I don't think so. That's what I really myself.
You don't think so? You have no chance of flipping. Earlier he
earlier you said you probably wouldn't >> Okay. Well, there
you go. I have zero chance of flipping. Triple as. >> Yeah,
I have no chance of flipping. I'd just stop streaming before
I >> also believe I have no chance of flipping. Want to
say there's chance of flipping. I would say at most like 5%.
>> So on a one on a D20.
>> I am Why? Dude, Zip Zip, they they literally just I
hope Dude, it's actually crazy how awesome this is. I hope Zip
Zip appreciates that they just brought him in and they went,
"We have no evidence for this. We just think you're going to
it's going to happen. He's like, I WOULD NEVER I WOULD NEVER.
It's like you're already being accused of something without evidence.
>> I don't think you guys know me well enough to think
otherwise. I don't think you guys have >> I have total
loyalty. I would never flip. I'd help Destiny bury bury as many
children as I needed to. Okay. I'd hold down as many kids as
I have to. I would never flip. >> Me to think otherwise.
Seen enough of me think otherwise. >> I I've already told
you why I think otherwise. I think you're clout driven and I
think that you have a good chance of
flipping. >> Why do you think I'm clout driven? >> Because
you join this stream all the time and immediately insert your
opinion. Wait, did just go? You're like totally cloud driven.
You're a total piece of What's your evidence? Well, you sometimes
join my stream.
Are you serious, bro? Okay. Well, I mean, dude, by the way, Zip
Zip
is the most approval seeking person that exists on planet Earth.
He lives for Destiny's approval, Pisco's approval. I'm sure Dan
and Mutton's approval, right? He needs approval from these people.
This is like torture to him. Like, he is actually dying. Okay,
I can't play that recording from Pisco's,
but at some point in that conversation, just know that Zip Zip's
talking and Queen goes,
he does this like straw man soy voice at him and Pisco dies laughing.
And I think I could feel Zip Zip's soul rened in half. Okay,
I could feel it through time and space. His soul shattered when
Quimman, the most evil Jew of all Jews. Okay.
The most evil Jew of all laughs and does the soy man voice at
him and then Pisco actually just like cackles laughing. All
Cuz it was funny.
I I don't think I've ever Dude, it was rough. It was rough
>> I don't think that's
being cloud driven. If I were cloud driven, I'd be
doing a million other things.
>> Like not arguing with you guys about >> I don't
think that's true. >> I would probably just suck up if
I were cloud driven. >> I don't think that's true. >> Okay.
And either way, just being cloud driven doesn't mean I would
flip on Destiny like Jaytock because even if I'm cloud driven,
I would never flip on Destiny. I would never flip on Destiny.
I would never do that. That's what even if I'm cloud tripping,
it's like, bro,
like
this has to turn your stomach if you're in DG, right? It has
to turn your stomach.
It has to like it's it's it's
actually it's rough on both sides. It's rough that they're doing
this like struggle session. It's also incredibly rough that he
was like, "No, I did I did I did express ideas that are anti-destiny.
I showed I showed reasons that I should have to reprove my loyalty.
And you're right. I would never ever even if I'm cloud driven,
I would
Oh, it's bro. And either way, just being cloud driven doesn't
mean I would flip on Destiny like Jtock because
like as this has happened with all a bunch of people flipped,
it doesn't really get you a lot of clout flip
>> No, it it kind of sucks, dude. Well, hold on. Flipping
was fine. The issue was that like Destiny started accusing me
of like doxing and then saying he was going to dox anyone around
me and then that started affecting things, right?
Like that's the problem is Destiny is intentionally trying to
harass people out of my community and make it like evil to be
here. Unfortunately, in the process turning me into a super villain
without parallel. Okay. It turns out my very presence in other
servers
actually infects them. Turns them into evil places as well.
Comrade Wick. Comrade Wick, it appears you are harboring reactionary
conversations in your discord. Comrade Wick, how do you answer
to this charge? Comrade Wick,
ideas fermenting
fermenting disscent within the party will not be ex will not
be accepted. Uh
I think that what I said earlier I stand by. I think food shops
is absolutely in my mind going to going to eventually become
a Haywatcher.
I think that you have a chance of it, but I don't think you will.
>> Yeah. And I think your statement was far more reasonable
than what Dan said. >> But I also
>> I think that you have a chance of it, but I don't think
you will. Why do they think food shops is going to become a hate
watcher? Destiny is the only person who knew about their allegations
and was like, I still want to hang out with this person. Every
other person except Dev and Destiny were like, oh, all the you
said, yeah, I'm out. They're the only people who are like, oh,
awesome. Samesies, right? Why Why would she ever turn on Destiny?
Destiny is the only one of the only people with any amount of
platform online who doesn't look at her with disgust and disdain.
These people are insane. Like, I would accuse food chops of all
kinds of things. Obviously, like a terrible person, but would
never accuse her of being disloyal to Destiny. That's crazy.
>> Yeah. And I think your statement was far more reasonable
than what Dan said. >> Okay. But I Let's watch Let's watch
the statement real quick. Let's hear what we said. Yeah. Yeah.
Hey, Rhinox. I understand. Okay. I just want to make sure that
you get paid enough. Okay. Getting paid less than 10 grand for
that. You are underelling. Okay. You get You can get at least
10 if not 15. You get 15. You give me like one. I think we we're
all happy. Everyone's happy. Can someone film me on the food
chubs? Hey, the only takes I've seen from this person is that
Destiny is vindicated for his court drama. The leftists are a
huge problem. And that and Dan focuses too much on Hassan and
not enough on Asmin Gold.
What are the horrible takes this person? >> Oh, the is
me seeing all the DJs say they want Pisco and food shops as
>> Oh yeah, big time.
>> Oh, that's funny. That's a good one. It is true. Yeah.
All the quote unquote DJs, by the way, I will say Radiant and
Zip Zip, as much as we're giving them a pass, those are definitely
people that are like
they're firmly in one camp. We'll just say that much. Okay. Their
allegiances are not to DG. I'm just going to tell you that right
now. Okay. >> Big time. >> Oh, I see. I think,
>> dude. It's crazy how quickly
It's crazy how quickly, bro. I'm sorry, Dan. I'm going to I'm
going to play into this. I think I think this is concerning.
This is something we should pay attention to. No. Can you guys
see this on stream? You can't quite this prying mind guy. Dan
acting like he wasn't completely chill with Pisco or JTO before.
Dan was Dan was kind of chill with Jay-ST and Pisco.
I can't think of a single other person who was chill with with
JTock or Pisco before this, guys. But Dan was Isn't that Isn't
that an indication of Dan's true character that he could have
ever been cool with Pisco and Jtock? Isn't that true? Isn't that
Isn't that true? That is true, guys. Oh my god.
Dan talked to Sunday. Dan talked to Pisco. Did you know that
Dan stayed in Chudlo Logic's Discord through all of the times
where they lied about like the Lauren Southern stuff and saying
that Destiny was mean to Molina when they lied about stuff like
that Destiny had a relationship with Lauren Southern in the summer
of 2022
and they also lied about Destiny being mean to Molina. They they
lied about so much and Dan stayed there despite those crazy lies.
That's crazy. That's insane. No, I think that's Bro, I would
really be concerned that Dan might be at risk of flipping. Okay.
Oh my god. >> You n mythics for the sub big time. >> I
get you know I'm going to call it here >> big time. >> I'm
putting it out there. >> Yes. Big time. You guys support
your friend. Wait, hold on. Wait. Mutton was like, "Oh, I think
a little bit for >> Radiant Zip Zip. As much as we're giving
them a pass, those are definitely people that are like >> Let
me listen again. wasn't paying attention to the numbers. >> We'll
just say that much. Okay. Their allegiance is not to DG.
>> Okay. So, Zip Zip's problem is saying like you're not
you're not like loyal to Destiny. And they're like, "No, I said
that about food shops." Like, "No, I said that about food shops,
not you."
That's not true. >> Tell you that right now. Okay. >> Big
time.
>> Zip's just correct there. Hopefully, Zip stands on business
and says, "Hey, you guys are wrong on this. You just accuse me
of being like disload the Destiny despite the fact that I spent
all of my evenings arguing in Destiny's favor
and they're like
>> thanks for the sub
>> of you gaslighting. Uh what makes you think that we'd
like talk [__] about you like that? Are you insane?
>> Big time. >> I guess you know I'm going to call
it >> Big time. >> I'm putting it out there. Yes.
Big time.
Bo Moon Boon's like Boon hears himself say like the exact opposite
of what he was just telling what he's just telling Zipzip and
and he's like yeah big time yeah I stand on that >> guys
support your friend
and nothing I'm saying here is wrong and I I have proof so let's
finish >> yes 1 billion% yes
>> there okay >> the current people who have
the highest potential of just flipping a switch and going J-toalk
food shops
and zip. Dude, this is a not so cold war, isn't it?
Are we Are we the liberals? Did I somehow the guy who who loves
to pretend to be racist, loves to pretend that he's like further
right than he is? Did I somehow end up on the liberal side? Did
I somehow end up on the side that's like actually we need to
talk to other people and integrate their ideas, their best ideas
and their best people into our community? DID I SOMEHOW END UP
ON THE LIBERAL SIDE? I DIDN'T GET TO END UP ON THE FASCIST SIDE.
That's so up. I didn't get to end up on the communist fascist
side. I'm on the liberal side.
Dan Moot doing a power struggle with lesser orbiters. Yeah, we're
watching the struggle session of Zip Zip right now. We're we're
trying to determine levels of Jtockness.
Sweatpants freedom. Okay. We're looking for levels of Jtock
proclivity. Okay. What? What is your What is your J-Tock percentage?
What percentage do we
They show a video. They attach a bunch of leads to your head
and they show a video of a Palestinian children burning to death.
And if you have an emotional response, they're like, "Yeah, this
is His Jtock levels are off the charts. Get this guy out of here.
He's going to turn on Destiny for sure. Absolutely.
>> I don't think will do it." >> Oh, I don't think
JC will take them. >> Oh, no. No. I'm just saying they're
going to flip the switch like J. Oh,
>> uh we we would take Zip Zip. We we don't take the Well,
we take Zip Zip. I I love By the way, it is actually personally
offensive to me that Zip Zip goes around with a Drist logo. Okay.
That [__]
All right. I love I love D and D. I love the Forgotten Realms.
[__] that. Okay. But I can talk to this guy about
stuff. No, no, no. We would take Zip Zip in. We take Zip Zip
in. They'll both go. >> They'll become anti fans. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. I don't think >> Listen, people
are always talking about the door handles with Zip Zip. What
I really want to know is
>> uh I can't find the Pixie tweet off the top of my head,
but like apparently her shoes were stolen at that court hearing.
I don't know how this happened. Like like realistically, she
just I remember her tweeting it and then Zip Zip says he went
her shoes were stolen. I just I would we'd probably have to get
to the bottom of that. Okay. If he could return the shoes to
Pixie,
I think we could accept Zip Zip. I think >> I don't think
Jtock will take them. >> Oh, [snorts] no. No. I'm just
saying they're going to flip the switch like J. >> Oh,
like they'll they'll both go >> They'll become anti fans.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. I don't think Zip I
don't think Zip Zip will, but I think food shops >> Oh,
for Well, I I would agree with you on that one. Also, I don't
really value anything that they've done for the most part. They
think that they're like it's easy to go and do when everyone
already thinks that you're
how do I put this? If you're like Harvey Weinstein, it's really
easy to go defend whoever you want to. You know what I mean?
Not that I'm saying this person's Harvey Weinstein. I'm just
saying if I was Harvey Weinstein, it I'll go defend him. It's
not like my reputation is going to get ruined as a result. It's
not that. It's not that. >> You understand what Dan's saying
here, right? He's saying that like I had a reputation. I'm an
upstanding member of the community. When I defend Destiny, it
matters. food chops was a with nothing to lose when she defends
him. That doesn't even register. She's already She's already
the same.
I'm glad shocking levels of introspection from Dan.
Um I would say he's overestimating his own reputation a little
bit. But don't worry, that'll
times are changing >> and difficult. You know what I'm
saying? Like uh yeah, I don't I don't take too many um I don't
really give a [__]
>> There you go. Okay.
I will say though that that is to some extent true, right? That
Dan did stick around. Dan was the only person who was willing
to go, "This looks really bad."
And by the way, nothing about how it looks has changed, which
is the funny part about a whole bunch of people going back, okay?
Like like nothing has changed. It's all the same. It's just people
who didn't want to look in. They just kind of look around and
see what the vibes are. That's it. They're just purely people
who signal with the group based on vibes. So nothing's changed.
But Dan, even when things looked bad and there was nobody else
standing around with him, Dan was willing to stand a business
and go, I don't care if this guy kills someone. I'm sticking
with him. All right.
So, he has he has some level of point >> Well, there.
Okay.
Firstly, I don't know why you'd think that food chops would flip
like Jay talk and become an anti
showing the vibe right now. I'm going to show [laughter] us why
right now. I'm going to show you why right now. >> They're
nuts. That's why cuz they're [__] crazy. They're
they're like the type of person that's like posting messages
they have with Destiny non-stop cuz And it's just so unbelievably
>> Is that something I do? >> So unbelievably parasocial.
Like oh my god, how can I post?
>> How does this make you like Jason? >> Look guys,
he messaged me and it's like it just makes me want to die inside
to be honest. It's just pathetic. It's sad. and people that go
>> kind of like doing this whole
struggle session right now about how Zip Zip's like not loyal
enough, right? Like you're you're doing a whole performance about
how loyal you guys are to Destiny while saying it's embarrassing
that food shops shows how loyal she is to Destiny. I I'm sorry.
Is the pot calling the kettle black?
>> Pot calling the kettle
an antisocial parasocial loser? >> [__] nuts.
One Direction. The second it the second it turns a little bit,
they go the other direction 180° just as fast instantly. That's
what happens. Okay? If you become obsessed with someone and then
they do anything to slight you,
they become the world's biggest antifan. The world's biggest
This is like factually incorrect, by the way. Um, I think when
I had I was really pissed when Destiny um
when Destiny asked me to go and argue with Dan about like the
Patreon pricing like through a third third party. He asked me
to go and like he was basically like freaking out on Dan. He
was super mad at Dan. So he and then Destiny messaged me gave
me like all of Dan like how the payments were working. Their
whole group conversation was like you should ask about this,
you should ask about this, right? And I decided not to press
Dan and use the exact numbers that I was given. And I thought
Destiny could have gone, "Oh yeah, I was like mad at Dan and
I think uh Dan's mad at Jto now, but he should be mad at me."
I thought that was like fine because basically the conversation
went sideways, right? I thought he could step in and not be an
avoidant loser and do that. And I was like, "Oh, this guy." That's
when I stopped even remotely trying to hang out with that community.
I just ran my own [__] after that, right? But I didn't
become an anti- fan. I just went ran my own [__]
It's like the opposite. This is like ahistorical. All right.
And then Dan and I began fans all started out. >> It's
just they're all pretending that we flipped on a dime. There's
no flipping on a dime, bro. Looked at the evidence of Destiny's
actions. We're like, "Oh, that's gross.
Now we sit here reveling in how some people pretend they can't
see it." Uh,
>> did he did he forget to order fries with your burger,
JTO? I have no idea. Anything to slight you? I don't know. >> The
world's biggest fans. Facts, facts, facts. Send me a fact cuz
I just said some facts. That is why I think that food truck so
cool. >> So I would love to be able to speak >> and
not be cut off. It would really
>> dude. Dude, what >> facts? Send me a fact cuz
I just said some facts. >> That is why I think that food
truck. >> So I would love to be able to speak >> and
not be cut off. It would really >> Bro, it's like the internet
dog. It's the internet. Just say I'm gonna talk real quick. I
need to get this out. bring me some pleasure if I could get a
word in without you. >> I was trying to speak and then
I got talked over by Dan. So, >> it would give me a pleasure
to be able to respond to you earlier asking me why do you think
food shop is going to flip? Here is why I think she's going to
flip. She is incredibly
parasocial as Dan just said. She thinks that like Destiny is
like super into her and watching her for two days. So, he's literally
not watching any other in bed for two days. Destiny, do you watch
me every day for the last two to three days? Oh. Oh. Uh, bro,
he's done nothing but food shops for the last 3 days.
This person has crazy potential.
And this person
is going to flip. She, in my opinion, is incredibly parasocial
and she's on the Oh, I love Destiny right now. What is the appeal
of this Mr. Bootin guy? Um, [clears throat] I think it's being
like essentially like a two out of 10
half-melted wax figure ogre that managed to date and marry somebody
who is a normal looking human being. I think he gives hope to
a lot of DJers.
He is like a he is like a false idol that can be held up that
they can have a future one >> But I love Destiny can very
easily turn into I hate Destiny.
I'm glad Destiny's watching me. Oo, it makes me feel warm and
fluffy. Go ahead. your turn.
>> Okay, so maybe all that's true and I'm not going to
disagree with any of this. Yeah, some of this is obviously cringe.
Okay, also I don't care if it's cringe. It's funny to me. But
none of that gets you to she's going to flip because like
Destiny hasn't been as much on her stream has been you know is
cool with you guys who for all your issues whatever issues you
guys think have with food shops that's between you guys and food
chops like Destiny doesn't really give a about this beef drama
right
>> that's not true did a whole bunch of a whole bunch of
content on this no I thought food chips did a whole bunch content
on this? What do you mean she doesn't care about this beef? Did
she do like two days of content on this?
Destiny just took her yesterday.
>> Yeah. And has she become an anti now? >> I It's
been eight hours. >> Yeah. But >> but that is >> like
this isn't going to happen from from taking the perms. This is
not going to happen. >> Okay. I I disagree. Like your issues
with food shops has nothing to do with whether she's going to
become an anti-fan or you think >> like just to be clear
also
is evidence that food shops was going to be disloyal to Destiny
was being too in love with
Their evidence is she's just too loyal. She just loves Destiny
too much. She's going to flip. Okay,
Zip Zip. But by the way, Zip Zip here absolutely incapable of
identifying how stupid what they're saying is. Just going to
keep going, "No, she won't. She won't. She really loves him."
>> Like, it it just isn't about that. I don't know why
you'd think that. And >> okay, what is it about? What do
you think? What do you What do you think it's about then? >> Food
shops is whatever. >> What do you No, what do you think
it's >> It was personal. Well, >> I would love to
hear Dan say what what it was about cuz >> No, I'm asking
why do you think we hate food shops? Go ahead. I'm asking why
do you think >> I'd love to be able to speak? I'd love
to be able to speak. Okay. Instead of being interrupted, I'd
love to be able to speak. >> Okay. Go ahead. >> Okay.
Can I speak? >> Yes, you may speak. >> Yesterday
on stream
uh
when you guys were going back and forth about uh the truth with
food shops, whatever. What where it ended up and where that conversation
ended was Dan had called food shops. Food chops didn't was not
accepting that. wanted to make a truce after and then refused
to make a truce and he said,
>> "Hold on. Let him." No, Dan. Dan's gonna interrupt because
he hasn't food. He didn't mention the food shop about uh like
the harassment towards Dan's family, but that comes after this.
Dan in the timeline. Shut up. >> That's not true. >> That's
not what was said. >> Well, that is No, that that is that
is true as to what the conversation was. >> Oh, Dan said,
"No, no, no. I think food shops misunderstood." Dan said, "Don't
talk about me." Like, "Don't talk me and then we'll have no issues."
That was what he said. No, >> what wasn't eventually gotten
to was why did Dan call food shops? Whatever it was beforehand,
and I don't even remember what it was. It was probably some personal
or it was something where maybe it doesn't justify calling somebody
back. Or maybe it does. But either way, you could just say, "Hey,
I'll take that back if I don't
No, see that this where Zip Zip loses it entirely. Maybe it does
justify calling them a I don't know. I don't know. Can we just
let it go? Maybe this person is a But what's the big deal, guys?
What's the deal with people being mad at guys? He's Jerry Seinfeld
in an airport. Okay. Doing doing his standup routine. What's
the deal with >> or if you do actually think it and that's
cool, but then she's obviously going to be >> someone that
has called himself a multiple times ironically. And there's I
also have a clip of them saying that
>> done that, right? >> Okay. I don't think Destiny
has a clip of them saying that when a kid was walking down the
street, they were scared, so they had to cross the street. >> You
don't think Destiny has >> OH, NO. ZIP ZIP, THEY'RE SCOPING
YOU, ZIP. ZIP, DON'T SAY THAT. DESTINY HAS SAID HE NEEDS TO CROSS
the street out of fear he's going to assault A CHILD. ZIP ZIP,
NO. NO, Zip Zip, stop. Oh god. when
crosses into the real world. I don't think Destiny has a clip
of them saying that when a kid was walking down the street, they
were scared, so they had to cross a street. >> You don't
think Destiny has >> a clip of when? >> No, not No,
not like that. >> No, no, not like that. No, I do not.
>> That that's not like a What is even the conversation
about right now? You don't think Destiny could could be You don't
think it could be argued that Destiny's a No, absolutely not.
You can't lose. This conversation is awesome from every direction.
You literally can't lose with this content. There is no losing.
It's incredible. [laughter] They're like, Zip Zip wants to argue
something. He wants to argue for his friend, but he can't. The
the microchip in the back of his brain is like beeping. It's
about to explode, right? He uh Excuse me. Did you just say that
Destiny may be credibly accused of being a Zip Zip? Is that what
you're Is that what you're trying to say to us right
>> We were talking. >> I've given you examples of
why I think that you both >> Oh, yeah. And now >> could
flip. >> Hey, hey, Star Chatter don't know who you are.
Star Chatter, you're brand new. Boy, you've been here for a long
time to say you have, you know, all this Destiny lore. You've
definitely been here a long time. That's definitely not
getting one guide and continue with
>> Destiny has said worse for sure. Okay,
>> Just to be clear,
dude. [laughter] Dude, just to be clear,
as much as I might not love this Destiny guy, I don't think he's
ever explicitly said that he had legitimate feelings of attraction
to kids and was so scared of them that he had to cross the street
while walking by one. There's nothing like that that he's put
on cuz basically there's nobody dumb enough to put that on record
on the internet in like a YouTube stream. Okay, there's like
one person evering
annoying
>> and if there was then everybody in this sphere would
think that's super funny and part for the course and awesome
and then you wouldn't even have the conversation about food shops
in the first place. Okay, >> here for a long time to say
you have you know all this Destiny lore. You've definitely been
here a long time. That's definitely not
getting one guide and continue with the conversation.
>> I don't give a [__] about a star chatter.
Can we just continue with the conversation? Can you stop reading
chat?
>> Okay. What is this conversation about right now? What
are we What are we talking about? >> What have we not?
>> Well, now it's me defending food shops
>> apparently that's what it is. I came in to defend myself.
>> Yeah. I would rather you defend yourself than defend
food shops because I would if
we can always talk. Okay, then let's continue to talk about you.
>> So,
yeah. So, in the clip for in the clip, for example, one of the
things that Dan said was like, I don't value anything that they've
done or whatever, right? Referring
to both of us, right? But just speaking for myself, okay, first
of all, I don't care if you value anything that I've done or
whatever. Or even I don't even know if I'm not I'm not here to
like say, oh, I've done all these things. This is why, whatever.
Okay. But also, Moon, you weren't here for quite a while. You
just came back. Okay. I have Yeah. Okay. But I didn't say that.
But I didn't say that.
Zip Zip. Oh man, I need to start watching way more content. I
could have been messaging. I could have absolutely messaged Zip
Zip. Ask him like why he was like mad that Destiny wouldn't reach
out to him to come on anything else. Ask him like why he left
in the first place. Ask him like what happened with his wedding
and all the things he said about his wedding. How like Destiny
only came at the last minute, didn't really have any priority
for him at all. Ask him about that. Ask about his wife retweeting
the Substack. Has she apologized to Destiny? >> You're
you're arguing with Dan and you're having me as like a ghost
boxer here. I'm nothing. >> Listen,
[clears throat] in terms of psychological warfare, these two
shouldn't even step into the arena with Zip Zip. Zip Zip has
cut the ears off of his enemies and he can bring his trophies
back to DG. And of course, what I mean by that is he has the
shoes. He can show them. He's got physical trophies. What physical
trophies do you guys have? Mr. Moot, Dan,
what have you taken from the other side? Zip Zip has the shoes.
You got you ain't got [__] back. >> Okay. Okay.
>> I I Yeah. Okay. But I didn't say that. But I didn't
say that. You're you're arguing with Dan and you're having me
as like a ghost boxer here. >> I'm not saying
>> again. I'm not saying that you did. Okay. I'm just saying.
>> Okay. Then why did you just say that last? Okay. Then
why did you just say that last phrase? Why did you just say that
then? >> Because I'm about to lead into explaining to you
who was not here for a
I started in this community uh and got >> I don't give
a it doesn't matter to me. >> You're arguing with Dan over
this. >> I give a >> So, I'm going to explain this
to you, >> but I don't care. I don't need the context here.
I don't need it. I don't give a >> defending myself from
the accusation that I could flip on a switch. >> And that
there's a potential a high potential of doing it.
>> I never said you had a high potential. I said I don't
think you will.
>> You said the two people with the highest potential to
do it are food chops. Yes, that is correct. >> That's not
a very high bar to clear. >> That's not There's not many
of you. No, >> you would have a potential. >> No,
there's not. Yeah. So, that's why you two are the highest. And
I even said I don't think you would. >> Out of how many
people?
>> Well, I out of like three or four people
>> Okay, cool. >> It's you. I missed it though. When
did Boon come back? [clears throat] Uh, I don't know. A couple
weeks ago.
so for context, Mr. Moon, >> I don't give a [__]
>> I got involved. [__] >> I don't care.
No, I don't give a I don't
This is This is the level of intellectual back and forth you
get with um with Mr. Mootin. Um I'm pretty sure Zip Zip is going
to be disloyal and flip on Destiny. I I think Well, sorry, not
pretty sure. I think there's a there's a chance there's a good
chance that he does it actually. Big time. Big time he could
flip for sure. Especially food shops flips. And then Zip Zip's
like, "I just want to explain to you like why I'm in this community
and like explain to you so you can understand." He's like, "I
don't care. I'm going to make claims about you. Don't try to
explain." No. No. Don't try to explain. [__] you.
[__] you. Zip Zip. Amazing. Okay. >> And knows.
And he said what he said despite. No. >> I Guys,
what does this have to do with me? Why Why do I need the context
here?
I I muted him on my end for a minute. Like, do we give a Because
I don't Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Talk. You're just elevating
hearsay then?
What's the hearsay I'm elevating? Wait, what did I what hearsay
am I elevating? Hold on. Wait, what?
Hold on. I have to go back. I just need to know what hearsay
am I elevating? Wait, what is this, Crisp? What did you link?
What did you link here?
Oh god. What is it? Why did you link me a Chut >> Gary
for himself?
>> what is this? >> Trans Asian um JTalk.
Okay, that's the best word.
big words. Okay,
big words from Nicholas Dioro without the viewer ship or obsession
with covering Ethan's balls. Okay, >> guys,
what does this have to do with me? Why? Why >> do you deny
those claims? Yeah, I mean, it's pretty obvious that um my content
isn't even remotely close to >> Do I need the context here?
>> But I don't want to get too defensive. >> I I
muted him on my end for a minute. Like, do we give a because
I don't feel like he's
>> Oh, they muted Zip Zip. What the Why did they
just muted him >> to the arguments here?
Oh, wait. I
>> Oh, wait. Chud said he has a friend who watches food
shops. Yeah, a friend. A quote unquote a friend. I Guys, I just
I should have a friend who watches food >> Mean to server.
Yeah, I meant to mute him on my end. Sorry. I I don't feel like
you're responding to the arguments at all and I just don't give
a [__] about it. >> It's It's literally you,
CFKA, and food shops and you and food shops are the most likely
in my opinion to turn and I don't think you will.
This gangster Carter guy, you're really upset that I'm not fair
to Mutin. Mutton lies about me, but I didn't even lie about him.
I don't even know what you're talking about. Elevating hearsay
when I said that Mr. Mutton's wife totally supported all of Destiny's
victims and absolutely retweeted that Substack that was extremely
defamatory and she should probably apologize if she wants to
be in the DG sphere. When I said that,
I fully believe that. Right. If you're if you're a Destiny orbiter,
you should absolutely demand anyone who retweeted that that they
should apologize. Right. That was defamatory. >> In food
shops and you in food shops are the most likely in my opinion
to turn and I don't think you will. Okay. Cops up. Am I Am I
unmuted? Can I Can I speak >> I mean, you can maybe speak.
I might not. I might continue to say I don't give a [__]
>> You can not give a You can still just maybe let me speak.
>> Is the retweet still pinned? >> You don't have
to platform you at all if I don't want to. I I want you to you're
in here to respond to the arguments
that were that we made
>> and I feel like you're going off on some tangent that
I just don't >> the argument that food shops is really
obsessed with Destiny so they're definitely going to flip immediately
>> and it's not directly responding to anything I have
an issue with >> because it's directly responding to the
potential of me flipping on a switch like JTO. So, I'm going
to go to my record and explain to you why my record I think demonstrates
that I would not do that and I don't take kindly to being accused
of being
potentially able to do >> So, can I go ahead and explain
that? >> I just don't give a [__] >> You
understand why I might be relevant? >> But do you understand
that I don't give a [__]
>> You can just [__] talk to me instead of
talking to my face. >> What I didn't but what I did wasn't
talking you. I literally have said I don't think you would.
So I don't understand. >> You thought that I had a high
potential to do it. >> Yes. Out of three people out of
three people. Out of three people, you had a you had a potential
to do it. >> [__] aggressive right now. So
I'm going to defend myself.
>> I I just I don't understand how you're upset with me
and not yelling at Dan here. Dan is the one who said all of the
>> You're the one yelling at me. >> I'm not yelling
you. I'm telling you I don't give a >> I because I'm trying
to tell you I don't care about what you're going to say and you
should respond to the other arguments. This doesn't matter to
me. It's I don't believe he's actually made any arguments at
all with regards to Zip Zip. He's saying respond to the arguments.
What are the arguments?
Has there been an actual argument with regards to Zip Zip?
I Zip Zip's basically they're basically going based on your the
content of your character, we think you're going to flip. And
Zip Zip's like, "Can I just explain how I think?" And they're
like, "No, [__] you. Get out of here. This is very
funny." Dan got to be thinking moot and wildening. Well, I just
like watching the guy get bullied, too. So, >> between
you and three people, it's you, >> Food Chops, and Cfka.
Those are the three people who come on stream constantly. CFKA
seems like a really cool dude. Food shop seems crazy. And you
seem fine. You're normal. You're okay. You're fine.
>> I think CFKA is in a different league. I'm not worried
about CFKA. >> I'm not worried about CFKA in the slightest
either, but I'm also not worried about Zip Zip.
Um,
>> that's not what the clip said. That's not what the clip
said at all. H. So, seems like your co
>> Have you Have you repeated the loyalty
There is no greater evil than Jtock in the DG nation. Can you
repeat that for me? There is no greater evil than JTocktock in
the DG Thank you. Yes. Jtock is evil. Jtock is evil. Jtock is
I think you're secretly in league with Jtock. Now, you're secretly
in league with J. Okay. All right.
>> Yes. So, argue with Dan. That's what I've been saying
the whole time. Yell at >> Yeah, but you're the one [__]
talking. So, shut the [__] up then. >> You
because you keep trying to tell me something like I give a little
bro. I don't care. It doesn't matter to me. Talk to his voice
is literally cracking. I'm okay. Correct me if I'm wrong. He's
trying to address Dan, right, and say, "This is how I think."
And Moon's going, "I don't care about that." And now he's going,
"Why don't you talk to Dan? I don't care about that."
I I thought this was going to be Zip Zip breaking down.
This is like Mr. Moot breaking down. This is This is sad.
>> I didn't think I'd TAKE ZIP ZIP'S SIDE HERE. Somehow
Zip Zip is the least cringe actor in this scenario. Well, I guess
Dan's sort of abstaining, so maybe it's him.
>> Yes. So, argue with Dan. That's what I've been saying
the whole time. Yell at >> Yeah, but you're the one talking.
So shut the [__] up then >> you because you
keep trying to tell me something like I give a little bro. I
don't care. It doesn't matter to me. Talk to Dan. >> This
is the type of behavior that makes me sus. By the way, m you
know >> questioning questioning my narratives. That's JT
coded. >> I remember when JTO did that. That's that's Dan
that's Dan's thinking right now. I remember when JTO said I was
crashing out. Are you saying I'm crashing out right now? Zip
Zip. It's a very JTO coded thing to do.
what you're doing right now with that
>> the way you're just the way you are. I don't, you know,
like Supreme Court, you know, I know it when I see it. Yeah.
That's basically it. The way you're [__] acting right
now is like high on the sus meter of what I've seen in the past.
That's all. >> Okay. And I'm I'm happy for you on that.
Okay. I don't know if you remember. >> We had a very reasonable
conversation if you
Yeah. But I'm happy for you that you're happy. Okay. Uh, I don't
know if you remember, we had a pretty reasonable conversation
a few weeks ago >> where you came in with the same accusing
me of similar [__] >> I didn't accuse you.
>> I come to an understand >> what's the understanding
that I
>> can Can I speak maybe without being
>> Okay. Yeah, but my radar is just going off the charts
here right now. It's like it's like hanging enemy sub at 25 m
and closing. I'm very happy for you that your radar is going
off the charts. Can I speak?
>> Yeah. So, last time we had a conversation about this.
I explained to you to give you more context and remind you, first
time I joined anything DG like on stream related was early this
year back in January. I joined Darius's stream on stream that
you were on
and I eventually ended up staying on Darius's stream being a
regular guest of his DG after hours thing uh for the month that
Destiny went uh didn't stream after the Pixie suback dropped
and for a while after that when he was still doing it
uh I ended up being like co-host basically of the show for a
bit uh where we just were defending Destiny against anti-fans
and debating anti fans.
Okay. Eventually over the summer I went to Destiny's court case
>> and I came away with my scalps
>> stream talk about it
>> and then eventually I started streaming a couple months
ago, right?
>> Oh, hold on. This guy says, "Respectably, my man, it
feels like you aren't engaging with the supposed doxing your
community is doing while still standing by all the weird stuff
you're So, uh, you're just lying, Gangster Cartic. Destiny doxed
people in March of
What doxing did? what doxing happened that gave him reason to
go after and start doxing people. I'm telling you that he is
selling you like reverse chronological order. He's selling you
something and it's taking basically responses possible responses
which I don't even think they're responses but possible responses
and saying well actually that's what caused me to dox people
back then. So there is still there is no credible evidence that
I've helped dox somebody that my community's helped dox somebody.
There is nothing like that. Okay. The thing with Rose and Cyba
not doxing.
So, you're saying I'm not credibly engaging? I did engage with
all of this stuff yesterday. Okay. So, I'm not going to let it
invade my stream today. Already made a statement on it. But you
are just lying. You are just
If you can't understand these points, please leave this chat,
join the Discord, and hop on the stream so I can explain it to
you slowly. Thank you. >> When? What time?
>> When? What? >> When did I ask? I'm sorry. Keep
going. >> Okay. So, you didn't ask, but I'm explaining
this. Okay.
So, I thought we came to a reasonable understanding. Like the
whole time I've been online for the past year or whatever has
been
like
defend Destiny from the most anti
Okay. Literally debating anti fans on this taking heat session
>> from anti fans for this debating relevant
debating real kin house jx editor doing all this. Okay. Eventually
food shop started streaming or had been streaming was doing destiny
defense
was watching food shop stream I think eventually I called in
I don't remember talking about what okay food chops also in the
trenches for destiny at a time when
Dan you could have left anything else for reasonable reasons
and mutton you went out in space okay now you guys are coming
back you guys abandoned destiny in his hour of you guys abandoned
destiny And you're questioning zip zip. Oh, he's actually he's
actually making some arguments.
Oh boy. I wonder how this >> That's cool. I like you guys.
I've been a DJ for quite a few years. Okay.
But now you guys are coming in with a lot of heat for food trucks
now. >> Okay. No, now he's Oh god. Am I hearing catches
in his voice? I'm not hearing catches in his voice. Am I?
>> I like you guys. >> Oh no. I'm hearing the wobbling.
OH.
OH, he's actually making the right arguments. And then he gets
the aura debuff from the wobbling voice. >> Left anything
else for reasonable reasons. And mutin, you were not in the space.
Okay, now you guys are coming back. That's cool.
That's cool. That's cool. That's cool. I like you guys. I've
been with you, J for quite a few years, okay?
But now you guys are coming in with a lot of heat for food chops
and I food shops. I don't give a [__] Okay, there's
a back and forth there, but I've never said anything about you
guys and I'm catching a lot of heat and I don't get it. It's
strange.
So,
I've done all the passed all the loyalty tests. What more do
you want from me? This is like this is actual dude. This is like
the communist where they like basically lie to you like repeatedly
if you won't repeat the lies like if you won't break psychologically
like people have total psychotic breaks, right? because you need
to just say the lie that they're telling you to say and they're
like they haven't even given him a way to defend himself at all.
He's he said the things he needs to and he's like borderline
breaking down because he just laid out the reality. He's like
but you guys are just going after me and I was like so nice to
you and I passed all of the loyalty tests and I [laughter]
what more do you want?
The heat that you've caught is me saying that you're one of the
most likely to flip out of three people and I didn't think you
would. That's a lot of heat to >> From you, right? >> For
you.
>> Okay. Dan also agreed that he didn't think you would
flip. I don't know what he thinks now. >> First thing,
well, hold on. First thing that came in when I joined this call
was I have very little issue with what you said except that I
don't think I have the potential to become an anti and flip a
switch.
Whenever you said that Dan went
well
so Dan doesn't agree with that, right, Mr. Mun? Maybe you're
going to speak for him but or maybe he's gonna walk that back.
>> I I think so. My guess, what Dan thinks right now, is
he probably thinks that you're on the same level of food shops
flipped now. And another reason that I think that he thinks that
is because if you're out there and you're in the trenches constantly,
you're way overinvested in all this. At the time, Destiny didn't
know you. And if you're on all these streams defending him and
going super hard, I just want to finish my point. If you're going
super hard, you're way overinvested and you're going to be way
overinvested when he eventually
uh does something that you don't like and you're going to go
on the complete opposite end. So you're over.
So that just doesn't make sense. At least in the in the Jtock
centered world that they operate, right? The where Jtock is the
great evil is the great Satan. I'm basically America in this
case. Okay. in that great in that world where we have the great
Satan over there. None of this stuff is like relevant to me.
I didn't like Destiny,
right? I like kind of felt bad for the guy when he had his text
with Lauren Southern leaked, but I feel bad for most people.
I gave way too much charity to people, right? But I wasn't friends
with him.
I basically thought he's a complete douchebag after the Dan Patreon.
Didn't want to really be around. Didn't bother hopping in. Was
not worth it. Was not worth my time. And so I wonder why they're
going to compare food shops to me when that's like so clearly
And this argument also is just weird. Like I think Destiny would
be explicitly against this. Destiny wants that level of adoration.
The food shop's level of parasocial attachment is exactly what
Destiny cultivates. Why are they with his invested on one side
that he likes and you'll be overinvested on another side that
he doesn't like? I That's That's my point.
>> I think I'm invested to a reasonable amount. No. >> You're
hyper invested. >> I went on Dar's stream
to talk about this and I eventually just kept going on Darius
stream to talk about this. Started streaming a couple months
ago, a few months ago
to be another person in the space. People had been asking me
to stream, asking if I had a stream, whatever. I was like, "Okay,
I'll do it. Why not to be another person in space who's on Destiny's
side defending Destiny, being an orbiter, whatever the [__]
right? That's all.
Okay, that's all it is. >> Passed all the He passed all
the loyalty >> Whatever has been
this is like a whole thing. I don't know why it ever had to be.
>> Do you think you have more stick tuitiveness than Lyken
did?
>> Stick tuitiveness. >> Stick tuitiveness.
Uh, by the way,
what is this point even? What is this point at all?
Lyken literally has never said anything. He's never said a bad
word about these people. Dan. Okay, Dan, if you want me to not
just explicitly
start snarking you, you need to keep Lyan's name out your mouth,
brother. Okay? Do not invoke Lyken. Stop invoking Lykan. Brother
is totally out of this doing his own thing in the real world.
Shut the up about like it. Okay. Thank >> It's probably
better with audio
>> Was that spider joining?
>> Stick tuitiveness. >> Stick tuitiveness. >> It's
probably better with audio
>> Well, many people probably thought that Lyken would
never flip. >> I don't
>> What What does Lykan said? That's a flip. What did What
did Lykan do? Lykan literally was like, "Well, I'm not going
to deal with this harassment anymore. I'm out." He just off the
more do you need from Lyken?
What more, dude? They're doing the same thing to Lykan that they've
been doing that they're doing to Zip Zip. Lykan literally off
forever. He's not doing [__] right? Oh, yeah. He
defended he he basically said this e-collar is like fine.
But but Lyan's never said anything bad about Destiny. He doesn't
want the heat. He doesn't want the smoke. and you just completely
reintroduce him to this.
He's not hopping on streams and talking [__] about
anybody. He doesn't want to be involved. He's very clear that
he doesn't want to be involved. Involving him is cringe.
I'll criticize the people who go on these streams who do public.
Okay. But Lyan ain't doing Don't introduce him. Don't put him
back in the DG [__] >> I think that's the
>> he hasn't been around long enough. >> Hold off
long enough. Not if you're not if you're saying that, brother.
>> Hey, it's coffee. Can I Can I stop in real quick? I'm
not gonna I think Zip can speak for himself. I'm not going to
fight his battles, >> but as far as um like Mr. Mitten
Dan, I think it's I mean, you guys have been here the longest
and I'm not going to
second guess you guys, but I mean, one >> now, I'd never
accuse
Chairman
Saltman
of being incorrect. I would never accuse Chairman Saltman of
being incorrect, but I do believe Comrade Zipzip
has shown loyalty to the party. He's battled reactionaries all
across the land. What more could you ask for in a [laughter]
in a exemplar of our society? Okay. >> Thing I will say
is uh you know >> this is this is not Spider, this is CFKA.
This is not >> I think it's fair that you guys are protective
of your friend Steven and all that stuff. I just wonder like
when you guys do this open speculation about like who people's
flipping. I mean it's good memes. The community likes it. I get
it. But like it does kind of it kind of like sets an expectation
and it it it does kind of make people uneasy at least as orbiters
because it's like you know I mean like I think Zip
for me everything I've seen from Zip is that he cares a lot about
Steven and wants him to do well. Everything I've seen from boot
traps is the same. And I'm not going to like sit here and defend
either of them, but like it feels a bit like you guys are undermining
people that want what's best for Steven by doing this open speculation.
I mean it I mean unless you guys are genuinely being this is
just memes. You guys don't mean it. Like if that's the case,
fair enough. I'm you know soy for saying it, but it does feel
like kind of you're coming at people
>> uh you guys may not realize it in
>> your race. Thank you Ken the jelly man for the gifted
sub. Appreciate it. in your race to do what's best for Stephen.
You may have lost sight of what's best for Stephen. And I'm here
to tell you that what's best for Stephen may not be how you're
trying to best serve Stephen. You may be not serving Steve. Dude,
it's it's actually it's it's some wild stuff we have going on
here, okay? >> That are trying to help the community. Do
you know how you would say that you would know a relationship
is strong is you can't really know how strong your relationship
is until it's been through some trials and tribulation. Someone
that's always been wealthy, never had to face adversity with
their spouse, never had a big argument, gone their entire life
without having to really deal with any drama, they don't know
how good that relationship is. It's only moments like this where
you find out who's actually in it for the long haul versus those
who are only there as a matter of convenience and clout ability
to get it. And I think that conversations like these are important
to see how people react to external stimulus suggesting that
perhaps they are not a
you see in order to advance in the party there is a seniority
limit. Okay? It doesn't matter that you've done good acts. I've
done good acts when nobody is watching. Zip zip you've only done
good acts in the public eye. How do we know what your private
intentions truly are when you haven't had to face adversity?
>> Uh, good person and go from there. And also the >> Yeah,
these guys could totally win. Yeah. Wait, what did didn't Moot's
wife like didn't Moot's wife like retweet Pixie Substack? Didn't
Moot like leave because he felt like Destiny was a totally inhuman
cold like lizard person? Didn't Isn't that like a thing? Wait,
Dan, hold on. Wasn't Mutton like super mad that Destiny wouldn't
talk to him directly to ask him to come on their podcast? The
podcast he was supposed to be on? Wait, Dan, hold on. Dan, excuse
me, Dan, your podcast co-host, has shown disloyalty to the party.
How can you, Dan Saltman, lecture us on loyalty to the party?
When you podcast with somebody who has shown disloyalty, how
can you do this? >> The what I would classify this as a
tremendous overreaction to a meme thing. You know who's not in
here flipping out? Radiant, who's growing on me, honestly a little
bit. Would you say as well, Mr.
>> I I think Radiant is a really chill person and I'm very
surprised at how
>> they haven't gone [__] Yes. They have not
gone memes. Yeah, >> they haven't gone mental. Um, even
though I see that they're still doing like [clears throat] a
little bit behind the scenes uh type of that's uh something that
they can can do. The thing is how you react to things is almost
as important as what you do in the first place. And I I'll just
say that um I think that uh um
it's not so much for you. I just genuinely feel that I feel food
shops is mentally unwell. Okay. Like literally mentally unwell,
not a good person. No one that I want to be around with. And
then the things that they say makes me
susted out to be around them. That's it.
>> they've just actually described being attracted to kids
on more than one occasion, like multiple occasions.
Um, and not like ironically as a joke, like they've very often
said it seriously as a problem they have to overcome and not
>> there's nothing more that I can say than that. It's
just like across the board, uh, there I see almost no redeeming
qualities except for the fact that they're willing to fight with
people that Destiny hates. So, they're a useful tool, but they
sure as ain't my friend. They sure as ain't anyone that I want
to hang around with. And if someone came in here saying that
they wish that uh Mr. Mutton's wife would get harassed or swatted,
I would never talk to that mother ever again. So, I'm happy for
them to go out and uh you know, do whatever and and you know,
be a useful tool, but let's not joke ourselves and say that this
person is like a friend of the community or anything along those
lines. They're here for clout. They were irrelevant before and
they'll be irrelevant after. And eventually when that happens,
they'll turn to hating Steven like they always do because that
will be the next way that they get clout cuz that's all that
these people typically care about. That's it. Um I stand by that
pretty good. >> I'm I'm not here to scold or tell you what
you can or can't say. >> Guys, it's just cuz like it's
just because they're looking for clout that people turn on Stephen.
There's no way a reasonable, kind, empathetic person could believe
that Destiny, the person who is openly explaining how he will
gain he will get revenge after his court case on Pixie. The person
who objectively by any standard had her nudes leaked had her
porn had material of her leaked because of Destiny's indiscretions.
But it's like he's going to go after her and just try to destroy
her life. And everybody should be comfortable with that. If you
think that's weird, you should go. If you think it's weird when
this person acts like a totally antisocial
like cold lizard brain freak, if you think that's weird, if you
think that's bad, you got to go. You're clout. You're just clout
driven. And you're part of all the clout driven people who will
turn on Stephen and then say bad things about him. Like that
he leaked videos that he leaked videos to other people without
their consent, right? that he sent sorry videos of someone. He
recorded things with to someone else without the third party,
without the other party's consent. And that's weird. That's a
Sorry, that's not weird. That's normal. That's like everybody
does that. It's totally normal here. And if you have a problem
with it, you got to go. >> Hey, I'm just saying it, you
know, I think for some of the newer people that are trying to
come in, like there's already a pretty strong resistance by the
community against people joining as orbiters. Like I faced that,
I know Zip is facing that and whatever. And it's just like I
I mean like it just feels to me like I hear you on you know people
need to be tested to see if a relationship matters. I think you
kind of but like us coming in here and speculating before we
see that moment. Um I don't know. It feels a little bit unfair
to me but I'm not going to >> I think we were I think we
were maybe a little bit unfair to Zip Zip and they shouldn't
have been lumped in with the with food shops. >> Yes. But
the way they reacted has not been good. >> Has not been
good. Now I fine. >> Yeah. I just want to say one more
thing. Um, I do think that
we I I think a lot of people who come in to the I I don't know.
It's a cringe term. The orbiters. I I think a lot of them don't
know when the to join and when the to leave and when the to shut
up in the call. It's a skill that you have to learn. I think
you're very good at CFKA. You come in, you do your launch. >> No
way. Hold on. Moon just got totally wrecked. Moon just got totally
That's so funny. Oh my goodness.
>> Some of you need to learn what to shut the up. That's
irrelevant. Kind of proving his point, but also just being like
Putin was saying something like don't speak unless I think you
should speak. Right. He's also saying something totally. So it's
hilarious that Zip just did the thing to actually destroy him.
>> So you're going to tell me what's not
>> This is something to do with what's actually like is
being like the accusations here. >> Yes, it 100% does.
And I'm >> revenge. Revenge of Zip Zip. Punish Zip
>> Getting there. >> What's the
>> See, when you disagree with me, when you say I'm a Zip
Zip, that's actually proof that you're most like Jtock. That
sounds like a very J-sock coded thing. Criticizing somebody,
saying they're dumb for saying something. It's like a very J-sock
coded thing. Are you sure that you're not harboring that? Are
you sure you do not have a bouncy ball in your room? Are you
positive?
I believe you may be bouncing at this very moment. OH, NO. IT
MUTED. NO, SORRY. IMMUTED. muted muted. >> Yes, it 100%
does >> getting there. >> One second. Zip. I think
it's the deal is is that I think that people like and this is
you know something where I think it's it's again people are leaving
room open for speculation. Zip I think you join and you want
to contribute and all that stuff and that's great. I think for
some people they feel like you have contributed zip you are now
done and you can sign off or something and so that's why people
tell you to get out and whenever you don't people can look at
that and go >> and people can Yeah. And that's and it's
fine and I'm not telling you what to do or not, but people will
then say, "He's doing this. Why is he doing it? It's probably
for clout. This guy's cloud driven. Now, I'm going to look at
all of his actions through the lens of him looking for clout."
And I don't think that about you, but whenever people do that,
who do they think about, right? They think about the stalker.
They think about Hassan. They think about Bosch, people that
are very clout driven and how they've acted with Destiny's relationship.
And I don't think it's necessarily fair to lump you into that,
but I do think it's like it's something that like I would expect
that kind of speculation from people. It's one of the reasons
why I personally try very hard not to overstay and it's one of
the things where like but but also for me I do not have as much
of an investment in an online presence. I'm more interested in
just finding content for the community and and then
>> wow totally >> having that go. It's not really
I don't really I'm not really interested in being a personality.
I'm more interested in just finding ways for the community to
enjoy, you know, being together and doing stuff. >> Well,
you also like jumping on and like being able to say your thing
on the stream and like get your like opinion heard, right? Like
I would assume so.
>> Um, sure, that's fair. But like the the other side of
that is like whenever I'm done doing that, I go back to just
being in chat, right? >> Yeah. Well, I'm not saying that's
a bad thing. 100%.
>> I was trying to say that in like a that's a good thing.
Like that's a that's a good thing that you can do. Like it's
good that you can go in there, get your opinion out, and
>> the tweet is up. So go ahead. Go ahead, mosy on over
to Twitter. All right, juice that tweet. Okay, juice that tweet.
Very important you juice that
Let's let's get that to lift off if you guys don't mind. Go ahead.
Juice that tweet. Thank you very much. >> Have a meaningful
conversation with >> If you By the way, I consider every
like, retweet, comment on this tweet the equivalent of a $5 donation.
Okay, you just go engage with this tweet. go do it now. Thank
you very much, >> Steve. And then when you don't have any
more, I guess, then you you you
go out. You're you're out of there. So, I guess my whole point
was like I think it's I think people just need to have more self-awareness
of when their time is done. Um like when I'm going to give an
example here, when irrelevant joined
and was talking to Steve, I was pretty much shutting the up.
And then Zip Zip joined and then Zip Zip tried to like in my
opinion insert themselves into that conversation and took a lot
of it when that should have been a cool moment for Steve to talk
to relevant and that was just a that that is a micro that is
a microcosm of the issue in my opinion. >> I'm really important
not irrelevant. >> Sorry I meant IRI. Yeah, I meant IRI.
>> Yeah, I meant >> and that's that's fair to think.
Okay, >> I don't necessarily disagree. Okay. I talked more
than I expected to whenever I hopped on cuz I hopped on I don't
even remember what it was about. I think it was about impeaching
Sanders or some [__] like that. It ended up being
more about that but because >> Oh, I'm back. I'm back.
I'm back. First of all, I was like, "Wait, how relevant talk?"
I was like, "Whoa, there's no shot talked to Destiny. I didn't
hear about it. Somebody would have told me immediately." So,
it's IRI. Also, people did this back in the day, too. Why are
you gunkarding Destiny's stream or like his Let Destiny do that?
You think Destiny's incap? Well, hold on. Destiny is a little
bit incapable of managing that. He's totally avoidant. But like,
you don't have to do that. That's I feel like that's cringe.
You mixed up and rei who does that. Well, someone who takes a
bunch of time off because Destiny treated them like they weren't
really friends and he's upset about that and now he used to come
back and try to catch up. >> Okay. I talked more than I
expected to whenever I hopped on cuz I hopped on. I don't remember
what it was about. I think it was about impeaching Senators or
some [__] like that. It ended up being more about
that, but because it became a back and forth where it was responding
to me, I think I said a couple things about it as well. >> But
you but >> Oh, wait. I'll let you finish.
>> Yeah, I joined to say something. I had something to
say. I said it.
>> And you can disagree. That's that's >> but I wasn't
there to like clout farm from Ira. Right. >> Right. And
well, and two things with that. Like one, I think like whenever
especially when it's on Destiny's stream, like Destiny's a big
boy. He can ask people to leave if he doesn't want them to be
there. And so like if if if there needs to be a better management
of like the content on stream, I feel like that's more of a conversation
with Steven than with the people that come on. And then and then
two, you know, I think that like it's really hard for me to look
at like Zip Zip coming on having genuine arguments. Maybe people
disagree with him, these things like that. and maybe he oversees
or whatever, but like it to me I think it is a it is a bit of
a jump for people and I'm not necessarily putting on you. I think
a lot of people are putting this on Zip a lot that he's very
cloud driven. I think that he's early on he's figuring out where
where his place is and all this. He's trying to build something
out for himself and I think people are kind of holding that against
him a lot. Not to, you know, you know, glaze him too hard here.
But yeah, that's all I want to say real quick. I >> I am
not mad at Zip Zip right now. >> I don't think you are.
>> All I'm trying to say are either. All I'm trying to
say is people need to know when to join and they need to understand
when Steven is doing a YouTube like moment. Him talking to IRI
could have absolutely been a YouTube video. Um,
and I think Zip Zip unintentionally.
I feel like it'd be so much more helpful if they were just honest.
Okay, listen guys, you were like the crew to make Destiny seem
like he was a human that people could like when everybody was
like sort of hating him. We've we've used you for propaganda
and now you're like really cringe and like useless and you don't
have good ideas and you kind of throw you kind of scare the hose.
So like if you could when somebody with actual like some amount
of actual clout comes on if you could off
that would be for the best, right? Like I understand you helped
at one time, but like your role is sort of becoming obsolete
around here. Like you are a cringe. You are a loser. If you could
learn to off when real people come on who we should actually
care about, that would be for the best. And I think it's my place
as Mr. Moot with without a college degree with no other re with
no other relevant experience in anything. Totally failed streamer.
Had to try to go to real life. Totally failed there. Came back
to streaming for the easy paycheck. sweeping for destiny. I should
be the person who decides this. Wow. Thanks, Moot. You should
be the person who desri who decides this. Absolutely.
For sure. Joined at just the wrong time. You have to you have
to pick and choose your moments when to join. You shouldn't be
in there all of the time. Especially in my opinion, if you're
not his I I don't know if you guys are friends. So, I I would
assume not, but I I have no idea. I think Steve has a very close
group of friends and it's usually uh it's usually girls. Okay.
So, what I'm what I'm trying to get here is if you don't want
to be hated by the community, and this is something I had to
learn, you have to pick and choose your times to [__]
>> I don't
Okay, so a couple things there. Okay, first of all, I have no
like delusions about my level of friendship with Destiny. Okay,
for one thing, >> let's just be very clear about Mr. Moot,
okay? When Mr. Moot deluded himself into thinking he had a choice,
he off, right? When Mr. Putin was totally delusional. Thought
that he could do something else with his life, have any amount
of
heed off. He was nowhere near destiny. Right? When that delusion
was shattered, he came back. That is who Mr. Mootin is. Secondly,
I don't give a
community. I don't care. >> Okay, that's a cope. >> Thirdly,
sometimes like like yesterday, okay,
like I just stayed in the call and was just like interjecting
every now and then. You guys were playing hardcorers. >> That
was fun. I literally just stayed cuz it was funny cuz people
kept going every 5 seconds. >> Zip zip you can leave now.
Zip you can leave. It's funny as >> so I stayed.
>> no problem with that. >> It's purely just it's
just funny to me. >> But that was a fine time to join.
Nothing was happening. >> Idiot. And I don't think I don't
think you're talking about that. But just as an example that
Right. Okay. The thing that's fair enough. I think there's a
difference between either. I don't I could even say, "Yeah, maybe
I cooked the content."
>> Yes. Yes. Just kidding. 76 Zip Zip is the same guy,
the same who told esports Batman to cry more about being doxed.
Yes. And then had the audacity,
okay, as Pixie would say, the audacity
complain that morale made a joke at him.
Yes. This is the same guy who said, "Huh, cry more, loser, about
esports Batman actually getting doxed." And then Morau said,
"Uh, actually, I have a video of you a 14-year-old Zip Zip. I'm
going to come to your house to show it to you."
And that was apparently more offensive, more horrifying
than Destiny literally doxing esports Batman. Okay. Okay, dude.
>> Okay. I joined to talk about what they were talking
about. It ended up taking a bit more time than expected. That's
all it has to be. Okay. But I don't think I don't know why that
has to mean on cloud driven. I don't know why it has to mean
any of anything. Dude, why is he one HP voicing again? You can
win. You Dude, this guy is actually spiritually limited. He is
He is total He is total
cattle. Okay, he is a cattle guy that is fundamentally limited.
He has every argument at his fingertips. He knows exactly how
to make them and he is just limited. He has this chip in the
back of his brain that will not let him actually resist. It's
horrifying. It's horrifying to watch.
>> Else I just I don't get uh
>> dude I got I got I got to listen to that >> I
got to listen to the whole thing again. I'm so sorry.
>> I could even say Yeah, maybe I >> I'm going back
even more until he starts with that. I got to listen to this
whole thing again. >> It's just funny to me. >> But
that was a fine time to join. Nothing was happening. >> Idiot.
And I don't think I don't think you're talking about that. But
just as an example that right. Okay.
The thing that's fair enough. I think there's a difference between
there. I
dude. Dude.
He's like actually Yo, dog. >> I could even say Yeah, maybe
I cooked the content a bit. Oh, Zip Zip. I was on your side.
I was Dude, this is so rough.
This is so rough.
>> If I join the >> I maybe I can even agree that
I'm not worth anything. Maybe I could even agree that I'm worthless.
Maybe I could agree that I'm worthless and I should just go the
thing. That's fair enough. I think there's a difference between
there. I don't I could even say, "Yeah, maybe I cluck the content
a bit." Okay. I joined to talk about what they were talking about.
It ended up taking a bit more time than expected. That's all.
It has to be okay. But I don't think I don't know why it has
to mean I'm cloud driven. I don't know why it has to mean
any of anything else. I just I don't get uh
I don't know why you have to [__]
>> literally this guy's like
>> Any of anything else? I just
>> Oh, never mind. I get it. That's why he That's why he
smiled because he's going to play the song. Literally literally
memeing on this guy's emotional breakdown. [laughter] No, no,
no. Cuz he said, "I don't have to what that I don't think that
has to mean anything else." And then Moot was like, "I'll play
the theme song." This guy's literally having a breakdown in his
struggle session right now. And you're like, "I'll play the theme
song." >> Uh,
I don't I don't know why you have to harp on it, >> dude.
No,
I'M SORRY. I THOUGHT OKAY, I need to I need you guys to understand.
And I went to his content. I thought that we reached the worst
part of him crying before this. I do think he is actually
possibly crying now.
Any of anything else? I just I don't get >> uh
I don't know what you have to harp on >> I I don't think
I've harped on it, though. If anything, I've defended you multiple
times in this conversation. >> I agree. And Dan's just
not really speaking up. But >> well, I disagree mostly
from Moon. Uh, and I'm I'm mostly >> He's being very nice.
He's a He's the I guess you could say he's the good cop in this
situation. Um, I just even throughout this conversation, I just
see >> I agree. DID HE JUST AGREE MR. Moon's being very
nice? Did he just agree that Mr. Moon's been very nice to him?
This guy's having a breakdown and crying and he just agreed that
Mr. Moon has been very nice. Dude, this is actually sick. This
is actually sick. And I am actually I'm sick for laughing and
enjoying it. Okay, I I understand I am fundamentally broken that
I could actually take any pleasure from this. I admit that. Okay,
holy, that was crazy. He's literally having an emotional breakdown.
And the guy who's like the impetus for this emotional breakdown,
somebody asks, "That guy's really nice, right?" And he's like,
"Yeah, he's really nice." Yeah, he is. >> So many of the
things that uh like you just should have just shut the up and
you would have been fine. I don't even know why you came in here.
This whole thing has made you look 10 times worse. You should
have just been in chat, called me a said said I was misspeaking
and then you would have been good to go. This is like the worst
thing you could have done. And now it's worse. So if you want
I'm not going to care. >> I know you say
I don't I don't care. I don't care.
[laughter] I don't care.
said said I was misspeaking and then you would have been good
to go. This is like the worst thing you could have done and now
it's worse. So if you want to look I'm not >> I know you
say >> if I look worse I don't care.
>> You can hear the you can hear the stifled so I don't
care but you do because you're joining the call to talk about
it. So why why are you care? It's fine. I don't care. It's fine.
It's fine. I don't care. It's fine. If my own actions have made
me look worse, that's fine. I can take that. >> Yeah. Okay.
>> I I I just I'm I'm not sure what to what to say to you.
Like even recently just now you said like, "Oh, uh yeah, Destiny
was talking with IRI and it was something so that's why I joined
cuz I wanted to talk about it." It's not, you know, like I don't
even think it clicks to you what what like what the issue is
>> You would do it again. Do you think I don't understand
what the issue people have with that is?
>> I get it. >> Would you do it again? >> I
disagree. Would I do it again? >> Let's say
I comes in here and he starts talking about some [__]
that you really care about. Would you join?
>> I might do it differently. >> Okay. You would
join differently. What does that mean? Like you would join another
voice channel and then like come in. This is the part where you
you convince them that they've been wrong and now it's like now
tell me
why you deserve this. Explain to me why actually we're the good
guys here. We just had to explain to you that that you did deserve
this and now you understand. So explain to me again why did you
deserve this treatment? Zip Zip, can you explain to me again
what you [__] up, why you [__] it up,
and how you'll avoid making the same mistake in the >> Would
you join?
I might do it
>> Okay. You would join differently. What does that mean?
Like you would join another voice channel and then like >> conversation
differently.
>> Versus when I came on if you came back and forth. >> You
just don't understand. >> Me and Destiny. >> It's
not about
that much on the topic cuz he didn't know that much about it
as he said. >> I I don't know what to say. >> I agree
Dan that it's not about me. I don't think I said it was about
me. >> But you're still joining when this happens. When's
the last time I was on stream? When was the last time I was on
stream? Maybe you can answer that one. before a couple weeks
ago whenever that
>> Many many months. >> Okay. Do you think that was
a good time for Zip Zip 45 to come in and dominate the conversation?
That's what people were waiting for.
>> Do you Okay. As I said, >> you're not able to
answer that one or >> as As I said earlier, I didn't expect
to dominate the conversation. Okay. It became a back and forth
with >> you know what the up part of this is. Okay. We
could do all the analysis on this. I'm enjoying it. I'm literally
watching every part like four times. Okay.
Um,
now the up part for Dan and Mutton is is this is clearly this
is horrible optics for Destiny, for the community, for everybody.
But now that I'm covering it, Destiny's definitely watching it.
I believe he was probably unaware of this before, but now that
I'm covering it, you know, he's watching it, too.
Ah.
Oh, boy. Oh no.
This is not a good look, guys.
Why didn't Destiny just kick him off the call? I assume he wanted
zip zip there. As I said, >> you're not able to answer
that one or >> as As I said earlier, I didn't expect to
dominate the conversation. Okay. It became a back and forth with
what I had brought up. I expected to just bring it up and it
was going to be a minor thing and then I was going to shut up
and see if there was another thing to talk about as well. I don't
even remember. So,
Do you understand how that looks like you're clout driven when
someone who hasn't been on the stream who h okay who has a YouTube
channel and everything joins and you immediately join and then
take over the conversation. This this is another example of how
I I
get there of like oh zip zip could turn. He's cloud driven now.
It's just not a good time to join for you in my opinion. You
have perms you can do whatever the you want. It's Steven's discord.
I don't control it. I just think it is a poor time.
>> Absolutely spineless
behavior.
Um, I'm going to make all these criticisms of you now. Technically,
you could do whatever you want. No, just say you don't think
you should do it. Just say I don't want you to do that. How about
just stand on your opinions? How did everybody in this community
learn how to offset as much personal responsibility as humanly
Like, it's it's a part of all of their mannerisms. Now, I'm not
saying no. I would
I I'm not making any recommend. Yes, you are. You're making a
recommendation. Just make the recommendation. Just stand out
business. >> And for you to join when someone who is another
big influencer joins the channel and is talking to Steven. Um,
and this is a big moment where they can both like have a [__]
conversation with each other and instead you joined. I think
that's just a bad thing to do. >> Well, I think we can
have a difference of opinion there. >> Okay. And that's
fine. But that like I get I get like I I don't I don't know how
else to say this. I understand why people think the things they
do about me. I disagree that I'm just trying to dispute
the >> You're just going to have to agree to disagree.
Am I right? Zip. Zip. Is that where you're at? >> That's
what it has to be. That's cool.
Okay.
That's literally who's why it came in to dispute the perception.
the the juxtaposition
of Zip Zip arguing and having no idea what his arguments are,
being totally incapable of defending himself in some of the calls
I've been in with him, okay? But he's totally confident because
his enemies are bad. But then he comes and talks to Dan Mutin
and he's probably correct that they're like just making up about
him and he literally can't. His his enemies are Dan Mutton, so
he literally can't summon the will to fight for himself.
Oh, this is this is a rough watch. Okay, this is a very rough
watch.
I just dude, there's like a test. You like go through a test
at some point. When you're trying something new, you're taking
something new on, you go through a test that's going to really
let you know if you should keep pursuing it. And I think this
is Zip Zip's failure of that test. Like basically you're going
to get tested and depending on how that test goes, it depend
it'll tell you how far you should go in life after that with
that exact path. And this was Zip Zip's test. He had all the
tools to like actually win this argument, stand up, make a name
for himself, and instead he
He cowed.
Very sad. Very sad. Um maybe he'll be able to I I don't know.
I I tend to believe that this is it shows you who somebody is
and from that point on like you know everything you need to know.
Maybe he could get it back at some point, but this is like this
is
>> I think we're going to have to agree to disagree.
[laughter] It's more >> you should have just not come in.
You've made it worse for yourself. >> I don't know what
Oh man. >> Dan, I don't care if I made it worse for myself.
Dan, really? >> I don't care. >> You don't care?
>> Yeah. Because I'm not cloud driven. So, I don't care
if people
hate me.
>> Does that make sense, Dan? >> No, not really.
When you come on stream to talk to people, it's kind of the opposite
of what I would expect of not >> I don't care if people
hate me for my own actions.
>> So, why'd you come in here to defend >> You don't
care. >> I care if people hate me because of care other
people are saying about me. >> So, you care if people are
talking about you, but you don't care if people are talking about
you. Moon, do you have to like translate or >> he might
you understood this a couple minutes ago. Moon
>> he's saying that he doesn't care if he makes himself
look bad. He just doesn't want people to think that he looks
bad because we talked on him.
>> Okay. But all this very hard to understand, Dan. >> It
it is a little bit. And all this does come down to what the public's
perception of you. And do you care about the public's perception
of you? Uh >> Dan doing his best impression of what you
guys did to him. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. This is
just the thing. Women and I don't do this. We don't go like,
okay, it might be a meme or something. There might be a meme
where we do something like this. Okay. But it's like we actually
just say why we believe something. Dan's essentially trying to
make it incorrect. I think this is like uh a maladaptive behavior.
He doesn't want to let it happen again. Right? If somebody says
why Dan's wrong, that's like in and of itself is evil Jay-Ser
behavior. Okay? That has to be evil at the outset. Just automatically
you're going to say that like I'm cringe right now. Well, JTO
said I was cringe. You're going to say that I'm crashing out.
Well, Quinnman said I was crashing out, right? Like he has to
he has to do that here. And it's transparent what he's doing.
It's basically like taking the cult members and saying although
you're all loyal to Destiny now, you need to swear your loyalty
pledge to me too. Very, very, very funny stuff.
>> I hear that it's an accurate perception of me. >> Okay.
I think that I think that there was like constructive criticism
given about how long he's he comes on to stream. Those kinds
of things were discussed. That's fine. I think the part where
it kind of goes past that is whenever there's the discussion
about him turning or whatever. I don't think >> I hear
what you're saying there. I think that's bifurcation is really
Reddit thread. Yeah. I I was responding to a Reddit thread and
I think we made a broader point about oh who we think will like
have the ability to turn or whatever. Um is that is that productive?
No. Um, [clears throat] this is finally some human being stumbled
across this content and messaged boot and was like, "You understand
this looks like horrible for you guys, right?" And Moon's like,
"Read the Discord message." He's like, "Oh,
well, okay. We'll I'll try to I'll try to bring this back.
Are we
I I think it's fine for us to call food shops out there in personally,
I think that that does more good than harm because I think food
shops is a bit of a crazy one. Um, [clears throat] should I ask
Zip in there. >> Pro probably not. Would I do it again?
No. I'll keep Zip Zip's name out of my mouth when I'm talking
about people who are going to flip. Will Dan do that? I I doubt
that. >> I mean, you're going pretty hard saying that you
will not flip and every I mean, not that you won't flip, but
just that you're not going to become an anti-an like Okay. >> Now,
obviously, anyone say that, right?
>> anyone anyone could be a J they could be secret Jay-
Sockers. And by the way, that is my preferred method at this
point. I don't really So Destiny, I think I was talking in Wix's
Discord today and then Destiny came to confront me and he asked
what we were doing and I was like, "Oh, I was just explaining
to these guys like your your like text to Willy Mac." And then
I disconnected.
I'm literally just going around like Saurroman, okay? Going around
the lands of men and spreading the good word. I'm just going
and spreading the good word. I just go, I join and then people
are like, "Hey, why did you say this?" And I'm like, well, I'm
glad you asked. Glad you asked. Okay.
[laughter] Uh, we're spreading the the word of the white hand.
All right.
But it's essentially there's no reason to confront Destiny. So,
I will just DM people and give them the evidence. I'll just I've
started doing this now. Okay. So, really anybody could be they
could be harboring JTO sympathies without you even knowing it.
So, I think you should probably figure out how to test people
best. like how to loyalty test them best because you never know
who I've spoken to, who I've provided like all of my side of
the story to and more people than you'd think are really willing
to hear me out. I thought I listen a couple months ago people
really weren't willing to hear me out, but it seems like the
doxing campaign has opened up some doors that previously were
closed. DJers,
no. So, I'm just having a great time. Okay. Having a great time.
>> Yeah, everyone does say that.
but uh I mean, you know, I don't give a [__] It's
not It's not It's not me that you'll become the anti fan of.
That said, um I'm inclined to like
I'm inclined to >> Do you know this saying, shut the up
when someone's like letting you win? Maybe you should do that
right now. >> You weren't.
[laughter] >> Did you take Desty's baby? DG. Oh, that's
a little far. Also, try to stay away from the child. stuff, but
thank you. But it's a little bit like that. It's a little bit
like that. Okay. We're just winning the war of ideas
subtly in the background. We're winning the war of ideas. He's
tried to put out a hit on us, a hit on our on our whole stream
here, our whole community. So, we're just going to keep winning
the war of ideas behind closed doors until it's undeniable. Okay.
It's going to become
>> Well, you wouldn't know. >> I can't believe that
you don't understand that Dan is being nice here. >> He
could go so
This guy's
you're time is limited. I don't care. It's time to make a prediction.
6 months tops. Guarant put put it on the books. Like you're you're
actually >> you KEEP FIGHTING FOR YOURSELF, ZIP ZIP. JUST
STOP IT. It's crazy that I've heard this said to Zip Zip in not
so many words twice in like 3 days. STOP RESISTING, ZIP ZIP.
STOP. JUST STOP RESISTING. JUST ACCEPT IT. ZIP ZIP. STOP
>> Uh it's like you're you're you're brain dead. You're
brain dead. Like I there's nothing I can do to help you. This
is how I know that you won't [__] make it. God [__]
Jesus. Okay. Yeah. Okay. >> That's fine if I don't make
it, bro.
>> Guys, I'm sorry. I got to I got a doctor appointment.
I got to run to >> I love you, Capa. >> Hey, I love
everybody in the call. Bye, >> See you. >> So, everybody
read the papers. >> The pragmatic papers, everybody.
>> Yep. Some good articles in there. >> Anyways,
[laughter] uh on food shops though, they're irredeemable in just
a taking time bomb. And nothing can anyone say on that front
will be anything
uh remotely any defenders of that uh insane behavior that they
have is
mental. Okay. Mental. >> Totally mental, guys. >> Okay.
Are we good?
>> Is it Is it done? >> You came in here. You're
good. >> Anything else? Anything else? Anything else? Are
we done here? Anything else?
>> Yeah. We're not holding you hostage.
>> I'm aware you're not holding me hostage. >> Okay,
but you're acting like we are. >> And no, you're you're
acting like we we should leave. Like, okay, are we done? Oh,
okay. My bad. We'll leave. We'll we'll let you get back to your
stream, Zep. Sorry. My bad.
>> I was asking if there was anything else.
Zip Zip is inflicted with a an incurable case of just being
the worst of
lingering. He's just a linger. He lingers at all times. He is
always lingering, right?
These guys are just like, "We don't like you. We don't like you.
Leave. We don't like you. Leave." And he's like, "Are we done
here?" It's like, "Yeah, they're done with you." Yeah. They just
Dan just did a whole thing where he declared, "You six months
tops and you're gone. [__] you." You're like, "Are
we done here?" Yeah, he just declared it was done. Were you listening
or you were not paying Were you not paying attention again?
He just said you it's over for you. It's over for you and food
shops. >> You guys had to say or anything? I [laughter]
think I think it's over. I think it's more or less resolved.
>> I don't >> Did one of them say anything? >> Acting
like we we should leave like Okay. Are we done? Oh, okay. My
bad. We'll leave. We'll we'll let you get back to your streams.
Sorry. My bad.
I was asking if there was anything else.
>> Yeah. So, I'm sorry. I I knew it was going to come,
right?
Anything Anything else? Did you hear him pause there for a fact?
That's particularly offensive. Okay. He like I just wanted to
know if there was
anything else, dude.
[laughter]
I would feel bad for him, but for the clear indications that
he deserves everything he gets, okay? Just absolutely. He This
is just somebody reaping what they've seown. >> You guys
had to say or anything? I think
I think it's over. I think it's more or less resolved
>> I don't think it is. >> No. No. I mean,
>> oh, with me? Yeah. With Dan? Absolutely >> Is
it really resolved with you, Moot, after what you see? Do are
you like, "Oh, yeah. This guy's this guy is golden. He's definitely
not a liability." Is that how you feel? >> Here's what's
happening. I see that it is affecting him, and I'm no longer
going to talk about him in that manner. Oh, well, >> okay.
That's okay. Cool.
>> the guy who hit the anything else intro while he was
like >> except that >> that it's affecting you and
that we're we're going to
>> Hold on, hold on, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I hate to This is probably This is probably the same kind of
Okay, but
>> can you say you're upset?
>> I'm not giving them this movie. I'm sorry. I understand
Desi likes this. I'm not giving them this movie. This movie is
awesome. I'm not giving them this >> You like a pig now.
Are you a rusher or are you a dragger or are you >> Hold
on. We need to get to this part. We need to get to this part.
Okay. >> Oh my dear God. Are you one of those single tier
people? Do I look like a double rainbow to you?
>> You must be upset. Are you upset?
>> No. So, you just don't give a [__] about
any of this? >> I do give a about this. >> Are you
upset? Yes or no? >> Yes, you are upset. Yeah.
>> Say it.
>> I'm upset. >> Say it so the whole band can hear
you. >> Say it so the whole community can hear you. Zip
Zip, >> are you upset? Zip, are you Are you >> I'm
upset.
>> I'M UPSET. >> LOUDER.
I'M UPSET. YOU ARE A WORTHLESS, friendless
little piece of whose mommy left daddy when she figured out he
wasn't Eugene O'Neal.
>> Hey, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. It's uh that is what we're
>> nice and not talk about cuz it's making you upset. >> Oh
well. >> Okay. That's okay. Cool. >> Do you you accept
that that it's affecting you and that we're we're going to be
nice and not talk about it cuz it's making you upset? >> I
don't think it's [clears throat] I it's not making you upset.
I >> So Mr. Mutton's lying.
>> No, I think he's mistaken. Damn. >> Oh well. Why
don't you correct him? Uh, I don't think I can correct on that
cuz he just has to like that's his vibes. >> We're just
going to have to agree to disagree there. >> Yeah, there's
not a disagreement on fact there, Dan. It's just
>> All right. Well, um >> Okay. So, I think it's
more >> So, when you become an anti fan, do do you think
you're going to join another anti-fan community or do you think
you'll start yours up from the ground up? Like, will you make
your own Discord >> I don't think any other Well, I have
a Discord. You're in it. Um, I don't think any other any fan
communities would accept me given that they all hate me. >> I
know. That's why it's going to be >> Not true. Not true.
Not true. Not true.
Uh, the only thing we need is for Zip Zip to give the shoes back
and we let him in. Okay. Zip returns the shoes to Pixie and he
is allowed in our community. He's all sins are forgiven if he
just gives the shoes back. Okay. >> Like a unique one.
Oh my god. You could be kind of aligned pretty heavily with with
Pisco, you think? Right.
because also that's kind of like >> Oh. Oh, is Pisco evil
too? Yeah. >> I Oh, man. I'm see that is the way that's
kind of like the I'm not doxing someone. I'm just quote tweeting
doxing someone. Right. That That would be the thing. It would
be the Pisco That would be the orbit you would go to, right?
>> Um yeah, maybe. I have a lot of connections in Pisco
server cuz uh I've argued with Pisco a lot. Uh >> why?
Wait, why did Dan bring why is he acting like Pisco is an anti
>> over the summer whenever PC last had a big disagreement?
I'd argue with Pisco for a lot of hours, so I've already got
those connections. I could I could go >> By the way, by
the way, just to be clear, Zip says in conversations with Pisco
that he agrees with Pisco on everything.
He he made it sound like he was just arguing because Pisco Do
you see what the cult mindset does to you? He's like, actually,
I went and joined when Pisco disagreed with Destiny before. I
went and joined and I disagree with them on everything. But then
when he's talking to Pisco directly, he says, "I agree with you
guys on everything."
>> Over the summer, whenever
he last had a big disagreement,
I had to argue with Pisco for a lot of hours. So, I've already
got this connection. >> I had to argue with Pisco for a
lot of hours. I am doing I'm spreading the good word. Okay. I
was educating comrade Pisco, trying to prevent him from becoming
a reactionary. All right. So I could go to Pisco but I when I
when I engaged with Pisco I was doing so with the
with the state's best interest in heart okay in mind I had it
I had it in my soul that I wanted the best nothing but the best
the DG I could I could go there. Um, but I don't think it's going
to be over the doxing thing because like that's already happened
and I'm still here, right? So, >> I changed my opinion
on that, I guess. But I don't know.
>> All right. I have a joke to make.
>> Okay, I'm listening. Are you like a reverse vampire
where you need our permission to leave? >> No, I was just
cuz Dan still has something to say to me. So, I was I was going
to see if >> Don't say Dan, just give him that. Just Just
say something to him and let him go. Dan, don't say you had nothing
left to say to him. Don't Dan. Dan, let him go. Do not do not
I understand that one last hit while he's down on the ground.
I understand how tempting that is, but let him have that tiny
shred of dignity and be like, "Oh, no. I was just kind of talking
shit." But you can go. Please. Please, Dan. >> Vampire,
where you need our permission to leave? >> No, I was just
cuz Dan still has something to say to me. So, I was I was going
to see if you know if there's anything else, but I think it's
done. All right. Thanks for the chat, guys.
>> See you guys next time. Byebye.
>> It hurts so much,
dude. Dan didn't say anything. Dan did it to him. Dan didn't
give him that one last bit of dignity. Dan sat there silently,
so Zip Zip couldn't possibly be confused. Okay.
Oh,
brutal, brutal, brutal. >> We got someone in stream disagreements.
What do you think they want? >> That's a post game here.
Who's in there?
>> I don't know. They're gone. Oh, you mean in DGG? Yeah.
>> Yeah, [__] it. I'll drag them up. >> I'm
so glad that somebody told me that I had to watch that. Okay.
I was I was talking to Queen last night. He's like, "No, no,
no. You have to watch it." It's like actually so brutal.
Holy [__]
That was wild content. >> Yo, what's up, man? What What's
up? You >> Oh, man. Can I just say that was the most boring
[__] ever? >> Yeah. You want to You want to
put >> That's so not true. That was so awesome. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Okay, that guy never welcome here.
Okay, that guy does no not know no content from a hole in the
ground. That guy is a total NPC.
Cops love in the bag.
I thought when you like totally broke down this guy I kind of
like I thought when you totally broke him down the way I described
that instead of like disturbing or funny or entertaining I thought
that was actually just boring when you made this guy break
>> It's actually only fun to watch Destiny break like Annavar
emotionally. That was fun. That was funny. But like other Oh
no, that was my audio apparently. Whoops. Whatever. We should
be back, right? Are we good?
It's only funny to watch Destiny break women emotionally. Okay,
that's all that's funny. It's not funny when you break Zip Zip
emotionally.
>> All right, we're going to Can I ask a quick question
though, like actually
>> Is Dan like asking him those questions just to piss
them off?
>> Like it's just bait cuz I think it's funny, but
you know. >> Yeah, Dan's baiting. You have to have a certain
high level of IQ, which you obviously have uh to appreciate
uh Dan content. So, >> oh, I love damn content. >> Yeah,
that's [clears throat] what I'm saying. High IQ hvers like yourself,
they get it. They get it.
>> See, sometimes you don't know. It's like uh Jreg's skit,
you know. >> I'm I'm sorry.
This is just transparently. They run this stream to build up
Dan's ego. Dan's literally paying people like Mutton must be
making at least 10,000 a month from this. At minimum 10,000 a
month from this. And it's he's just giving that crumb over to
Mutton so that his ego can be like I don't know like built up
in the eyes of this community. This is a little wild, Dan. A
little on the nose. Come on, man. Come on, man.
>> Well, it's almost like they're missing. >> Go
ahead. >> Oh, it's almost like they're missing out on like
the social cues of like I need to get out of here before people
start hating me more. I it. >> Yeah, we should purge all
the DJs who have um problems understanding social cues. That's
a great idea. Do you remember Do you remember the uh the post
about the canvasing events and how Aerite had to come in and
talk about how DG can't understand social cues and they're really
creeping women out? >> I I mean, yeah. I It's very strange
sometimes. Um they just they they lack the gift of uh >> Zip
Zip's got to come back in and they're going to defend themselves.
[__] You're about to loop here. I'm I'm on Zip Zip
side here. You're about to cause a loop. >> Oh, why is
Zip Zip listening to Dan? This is like Dan's thing. >> Yeah,
I don't know. >> He's been a part of the community for
so
>> Oh, that's a vintage meme, Matrix. Good job. I like
that one. It's an old one. Um Yeah, looping. We're looping. Um
I'm not not really. I'm just talking about how I feel. That's
it. >> Ask me how I feel. I'm not I'm under no
>> any watchers, you guys know if he comes back. I feel
like he doesn't come back. What the are we doing here? Like this
like the Darius version of um of mewing into the camera right
here. Let's go. So
>> I'm under no
>> Paul just got knocked out first round. Good on him for
not rigging it. Damn. >> NBA to be a certain way or not
a certain way. Neither is moot. I'm a free agent. All right,
we ready? Let's put the cops off in the bag, Dan. That's what
they >> Okay, I'm ready.
>> Okay, well I think that's it for that stuff. I was going
to do some of the Zip Zip content, but I do not believe there's
more Zip Zip, dude.
Just in case we ever get him on stream. Okay, we're doing some
avatars here. That's not funny. We just watched a man broken
emotionally. That's not cool. This is not hilarious.
Not good. Okay, dude.